I think most people have a dramatic
underestimation of how much volume it
takes to be successful they're like okay
I should go on five dates and then find
the girl I'm gonna marry what if it was
500 to find the right girl you're going
to marry I want to become an influencer
whatever it is and they start doing one
post a day for four weeks and they're
like why am I not famous yet we ended up
doing 400 episodes before we made it to
the top 10 on the podcast it's just this
volume game that you get the skill from
the volume the feedback from the volume
first time you squat you're barely
actually squatting you're just looking
like you have a bar on your back but you
learn so much between that first rep and
your ten thousandth reps and so I think
my goal if I can just decrease the
action threshold for people to begin and
be okay with the fact that they're going
to suck and it is okay to suck you
should expect to suck and it would be
unreasonable for you to be good if you
haven't done it before and so it's like
are you asking the universe to be
unreasonable for you by expecting to be
good on your first try what's the
expectation that destroys their ability
to be successful because they expect to
win on the first shot and no one does